today we are welcoming author Robert
Greene to the program who's written
seven International bestsellers
including the 48 Laws of Power The Art
of Seduction the laws of human nature
and others most of which I've read
um Robert really appreciate your time
today
thanks for having me David my pleasure
so one of the things maybe we could
start with is I've read a little bit
about your process when you write a book
and the wealth of material that you will
read and then how you will sort of
catalog and have a repository of the
things you've read in preparation for
the books that you write one of the
things that I struggle with personally
and I know many in our audience do also
is
how to have a system to determine what
is worth reading studying or paying
attention to today and of course with
social media and endless streaming
content and sports and history and
economics and all of the different
things that people could spend time
reading and learning about what's your
process for even at the top level
determining what is worthy of our
attention in 2023
well I'm very aware of the dangers of
trying to digest too much information
and overloading the Brain
so when I write a book I try and make it
as focused and concentrated as possible
excuse me I cut out as many distractions
as as humanly possible
and um so in the beginning I choose a
subject that can be rather wide-ranging
like power
or my fifth book Mastery and
um and then I read I try and find all of
the books that deal with that subject
that I think are going to be direct and
realistic and practical my method is I'm
trying to really change the way you look
at the world change the way you think
from the inside out and the only way to
do that is to actually have a really
solid basis in research in reality so I
can make the book as practical as
possible
so I sort of start by casting a wide net
and I read all the great books out there
on excuse me
for instance on power
and then slowly I start narrowing it
down to things that are a little bit
more specific and it's kind of a fun
process so if I just kept it too narrow
and I just focused on very small little
width of of books about power it
wouldn't be fun for me part of the
excitement because if I'm excited I
think the book tends to have to be
exciting to the reader part of the
excitement is finding things that I
never expected to fund so I go from one
book and then I look at the bibliography
it references another book it excites me
on and on and on by the end of the
process I've read two 300 books to be
able to write one book
and so
um I'm you know I'm reading an awful lot
but I have to kind of organize the
material and where a lot of books I
think fail
is they they don't they're not organized
well so I've created a system with cards
where I put I read a book and then I put
all of the material on it on cards and I
organize it by subject by category and
then I could show you if I ever if I if
you ever wanted my system of cars I have
thousands of cards for one book so I try
and keep my attention very focused on
the things that are incredibly important
and practical to give my book a kind of
this grounding in reality and then I
organize the material in a very almost
fetishistic way so that I can make it so
that the reader doesn't feel like I'm
overloading them with information even
though I myself have consumed vast
amounts of literature on the subject
do you have any overarching approach to
as a consumer of media in which I would
include books and all of the other forms
of media that are out there if people in
our audience have it their disposal
books of all sorts of different genres
as well as audio visual content music
all of the different things playing
Video Games Etc what is an approach to
figuring out what is quote worth
spending time on versus not worth it
which certainly would vary from person
to person is it objective based in terms
of what it is you are looking to achieve
over a period of time and which forms of
information consumption will get you
closer or how should the average person
think about this for you know reading
your books versus novels watching sports
reading narrative nonfiction about Teddy
Roosevelt or whatever maybe what is
there an approach that you could suggest
well it depends on on the individual and
so um one thing that I think is really
important is that you have a very firm
understanding of who you are and what
your life is about and your objectives
in life and what makes you different
from other people so so many people
don't have that deep connection to what
to what to what their um vocation is in
life they're calling and so they'll read
anything because they don't have a
filter so I think it's very very
important and I talk a lot about this in
my book Mastery that you have a very
very firm sense of this is where I want
to go in like this is what connects to
me this is what excites me so without
that kind of filter without that kind of
focus then you're kind of lost at sea
and you're reading all kinds of things
that aren't going to help you in the end
I mean at some point
I myself like to waste time you know
like anybody else so I will get on and
I'll look at YouTube videos or podcasts
or read material that isn't directly
related to my work and I think it's
important to sometimes relax and not be
so rigid about this but I think you have
to have a sense of where you of who you
are what you like what's important to
you what matters what where your career
is going and then from there you
determine what's important for you to
read because the problem we're facing
today quite frankly is we're just
inundated with too much information with
trivia that just clogs the brain up it
makes it very very hard for you to focus
makes it very hard for you to actually
think about your own priorities in life
so you can't
find an app or some teacher that's going
to help you do that it has to come from
within you have to have a sense of who
you are what makes you different what's
important to you what your values are
and from there you can then filter out
the information that's completely
useless or that's more important for you
do you think that at this point in time
it is still the case that there might be
some Core Curriculum of sorts the idea
of some kind of you know at one point it
was the classical education where there
were certain works that no matter what
your vocation or interests were maybe
worthy or almost like a required reading
of sorts does that idea still ring in
any way true to you today or has sort of
human life on Earth in 2023 becomes so
diverse that that very idea maybe is no
longer relevant
well when I was going to school it was
like these Classics from I believe it
was um
I forget the name of the schools like
Johns Hopkins they had a list of all the
great Classics I come from a Humanities
background
and so there were books that I rather
sort of the canon in there that were
kind of Elemental
um but you know so right now we're in a
period of time where scienceic
technology is dominating our our schools
Etc our way of thinking and the
humanities have kind of faded in are
actually being kind of closed off in
many universities people aren't
interested in them anymore but I think
it's very important to be able to ground
yourself in our history in our culture
in our civilization and some of these
Classics I think are still extremely
relevant and very very important to read
uh the reason is is it's not just
important what you read but it's
important how you read right so my
background in Classics because I studied
ancient Greek and Latin which is
probably the most irrelevant subject you
could study in University but I think
helped me very very much my ability to
organize my thoughts and organize
material
so a lot of these books they kind of
train you how to think how to interpret
how to read subtext how to get inside of
a book and take it apart and see what
somebody's really saying the the ideas
behind the ideas
etc etc I find that's a lot of that is
missing nowadays and people's thinking
is Getting Thinner and thinner and
thinner or they're not really analyzing
they're not going into any kind of depth
on the subject because they're so
distracted and they're going from
subject to subject to subject they're
scrolling
etc etc etc when you read a dense text
like I had to read like thucydides
history the Peloponnesian War it makes
you focus on on just one paragraph what
is he trying to say there what's the
meaning behind it it gives your brain
focus and discipline right so I think
reading going back to some of that is
extremely important even here in the
21st century and I I don't regret it all
studying perhaps the as I said
the most irrelevant subject of all
because I think it gave me a discipline
of mine that I would not have had
elsewhere but that said I think it's
important to have a wide-ranging
interest I like to read a lot about
science for instance I don't have a
science background but I'm reading a lot
of that for the books that I'm currently
writing and it kind of opens my mind up
to different ways of thinking it kind of
has a different logic to it than
literature or biography or history has
every kind of subject has its own logic
its own way of thinking it's some way of
exploring reality and the more you open
yourself up to these various different
ways of looking at the world you enrich
your mind but you also not just in the
content but in how you think so bringing
a kind of scientific mentality to my
material has been very important for my
thought processes so I would I would
throw a wide net out there and read in
many different disciplines but kind of
ground yourself in a way of analysis
pricing information instead of digest
digesting information having being able
to be critical and analyzing I think is
very important
along those lines in the books that you
write there is such a broad range of
both sorts of folks that you write about
and subject matter that you've read
about and you draw connections and
parallels between different eras in
history as well as between different
disciplines in all of that is there
anything that seems particularly
different about the current time that
we're living through that seems to be an
outlier based on the patterns and
connections that you've studied so
deeply in preparing all of the books
that you've written when you consume so
much material in history it kind of
changes how you think
and so a lot of people nowadays who
don't read a lot of history quite
frankly have this idea that everything
that's going on now is new and different
and modern it's never happened before
there's the old cliche in in financial
bubbles that this time it's different
you know like in 2008 with the new way
of doing a real estate equities that are
This Time It's Different you know with
AI This Time It's Different it's never
different it's the same patterns
repeating over and over and over again
throughout history I'm reading a book
right now about 12th century France I'm
writing about a couple of characters in
that period
it is incredibly modern the ideas the
ways people are thinking about love
about philosophy about ancient history
they're like characters that I see right
now in here in Los Angeles there's
hipsters there's guys with long hair
there's people discussing love and
freedom Etc so it's like they're like
hippies but wow this is this is
incredibly similar to our times we have
this illusion that things are different
the only thing that's different is
things get more intense so what social
media has done is it's taken qualities
that are inherent in human nature that
have existed for five thousand ten
thousand for a hundred thousand years
lack of propensity for Envy our need to
constantly compare ourselves like our
self-absorption
like our aggressive impulses and it
simply gives them a way to accentuate
them it gives them like a megaphone for
instance so our our kind of
passive aggressive tendencies or our
hostility on on the internet and social
media it's like it's just exacerbated so
it's not like things are it's not like
we've rewired ourselves it's not like
we've become different people
social media is having an effect on our
brains it's changing certain things it's
making things worse it's taking
qualities that we already have and
making them more and more extreme but
we're the same animal that existed in
ancient Greece in ancient Egypt Etc it's
just that we have tools now that we're
not really capable of handling in a
rational way our minds were developed
for a certain way of life that's
completely different than the 21st
century so we have these tools that are
so powerful but our minds aren't really
adapted aren't really made for being
able to handle them on a very realistic
way but I don't think the more I read
about history the more I have the sense
that human life civilizations and
cultures go in these cycles that just
keep repeating over and over and over
again so along those lines since you
brought up social media a couple of
different things
um in his two books amusing ourselves to
death and technopoly Which predated
social media Neil postman has an
analysis which if applied to social
media or a critique would be the
question of whether social media is a
net good is a less important question
than how can we maximize the good and
try to limit the bad Cal Newport on his
podcast not long ago had a piece about
the effect of what he calls unrestricted
social media use for young kids
particularly girls but both boys and
girls and he asserted that if the early
data ends up being what it appears to be
in something like 10 years the idea of
giving kids unrestricted access to
social media would be sort of like
giving kids cigarettes that it would be
like how did we ever not realize that
that was a really bad idea so sort of a
two-part question how interesting do you
think the question is of is social media
a net good and two what is your sense of
how the relationship to social media
might change as the as it matures and we
know more about its impacts
well you know things that technology and
things that we create aren't necessarily
a net good or a net evil they're just
simply instruments that we can use that
are at our disposal that can help us you
know so I remember in the early days of
the internet as a writer
the incredible power that it gave me for
researching giving me access to
documents to academic things to books
that I couldn't normally never get or
find it was amazing so it can be an
extremely valuable tool for gathering
information for finding things out you
have a simple question about how to fix
something in your house three seconds
later you have it it's also an amazing
tool for connection for communication
where I can communicate to people who
have similar interests like I do around
the world it can be fascinating it could
be a wonderful tool
but it isn't like that it's turned into
something rather dark and rather ugly
and it's kind of decaying our minds like
too much sugar would on our teeth
and the reason is and I said it in my
book the laws of human nature is that
this is what human nature is we create
something and we slowly slowly kind of
degrade more and more and more down to
the lowest common denominator it
happened with television and people are
going wow television we're going to be
able to use it now to educate our
children they're going to be educated on
this incredibly new level people were
that naive in the 40s and 50s and then
slowly would go oh no it's not like that
at all
so it's not the instrument itself that's
potentially good or bad it's our minds
it's how we use them how we bring human
nature how we have no discipline how we
just simply use things without thinking
about them
so the other thing that happens is
something like the internet becomes a
tool for making money instead of for
information for connecting for
communicating and how do we control that
we can't really control that because we
live in a capitalistic society and
that's the nature of these things but we
create these tools and we don't ever
think about how they're going to be
applied or the negative consequences for
them until it's almost too late and so
when I read now about Ai and all the
people throwing their arms up about oh
how dangerous it is even Sam Altman
who's the person developing this is
warning us about the dangers of it I
think it's rather ridiculous and absurd
for these people to be doing that
they're the ones creating it they're the
ones thrusting it upon us why aren't
they thinking about that before they
create it
why isn't someone like Steve Jobs
Imagining the incredible deleterious
effects that an iPhone could have on our
brains it's like it to me it all comes
back to human nature if we think about
the fact that we are very short-sighted
that we tend to be locked in the present
we don't have the Instinct of thinking
ahead and going what are the
consequences for this particular action
for this particular technology we're
going to be falling again and again and
again and again into this trap so I
think one thing that could happen as far
as dance is the second part of your
question is that there is something in
us that is that is very real that they
cannot endure so much of this virtuality
in our lives we know that we're ruining
our brains we know that it's making it
distract distracting us to death to
quote Neil Postman that it's having a a
net negative effect on our ability to
focus
and my hope is that people who are
younger who are in their early 20s gen Z
Etc they start rebelling against this
like when I my age I was rebelling
against the world of my parents and sort
of the rigid and conventionality of it
that people go we want something more
real we don't like this relationship
that's that it's creating of of so that
we're
less and less social and we're more and
more virtual and there's a real
rebellion and people realize this is
what matters these are our priorities
but until we have a sense of what our
values are of what's important and to me
what is important is that we're a social
animal and that we're able to interact
with people on a deep and a profound
level there were human that were animal
that creates and builds things in order
to build things you have to master a
subject you have to understand it deeply
you have to be able to be patient and
disciplined these are things that I find
as high high ALT Mega values meta values
that we must have discipline Mastery
social interaction creativity and if you
have that kind of scale of values then
when you create something new and you
create something like social media and
you go well how does that help us in in
these things is this going to have a
negative effect but if you live in a
time where there are no more values
whereas kind of nihilism where there's
no sort of there's nothing kind of
grounding us of what's matter what
matters are important nothing will ever
change we'll never get a grasp of how to
use these things properly
we've been speaking with author Robert
Greene we'll be linking to a number of
his books uh Robert really appreciate
your time I know you're busy and your
your time and insights are very much
appreciated
thank you David thank you very much for
having me